- Hello, I'm Seonghyeon and this is
my fellow presenter Inhwa.
- Hi~
- we are both media artists and research assistant of KAIST
We would like to first of all thank to JSConf Korea
for having us and everyone who are watching this video.
Today we are very excited to talk about our project p5
for 50+, which addresses the issues
of including order adults to coding education.
So, the major goal or p5 for 50+  was to contribute in,
enhancing the physical, emotional
and lingual accessibility of middle-aged and older people
to learning coding with p5.js.
Before continuing into our presentation,
we'd like to briefly introduce
processing foundation fellowship program,
which supported the p5 for 50+ project.
If you are also wished to engage in the community,
by enhancing accessibility to creative coding,
with Processing, p5.js or ml.js,
you might also want to consider applying
for next year's fellowship.
So check out the link if you're interested.
We want to start our presentation by answering this question
that many people would ask us.
why creative coding education for 50+?
Basically it started from our very personal wish
to better communicate with our parents and grandparents
about what we love to do.
And yet, if you look deeper in the Korean society,
you can notice some intertwined problems that
our parents's and grandparents's generations are facing.
While digital interfaces and interactions consist
of substantial part of daily life in Korea.
More than half of the older population feel
as though they cannot access what has become the dominant
way of communicating with their surroundings.
Even more difficulties are found among those who went
through their public and formal education before the 1970s,
which was only the dawn of the computer education in Korea.
To cope with these circumstances,
the government has recently offered digital education
for instance, on learning computers software programs
and smartphones.
However, fewer than one percent of the welfare programs teach coding.
Unlike the current trend of welfare policy,
we hypothesized that increasing the opportunity
for learning coding would be particularly helpful
for older adults
in raising their confidence toward
the user interfaces and interactions.
In a way it is about learning a language
for directly communicating with a computational entity,
understanding how the Computer "thinks"
and how it responds.
In the sense, we consider p5.js
to be our perfect starter language,
especially for those unfamiliar with machines,
because the inputs outputs processes
and entire logical flows
can be intuitively delivered
with a variety of interactions.
In fact, 500 people from around the world,
the world also from older age group
have expressed their high interest
in learning coding for the following reasons:
One, to overcome their fear towards the digital environment.
Two, to enhance their cognitive abilities.
Three, to re-educate themselves for planning for their later life.
To better document the older people's actual needs
in coding education,
we interviewed 13 people
with an average age of 62.
These interviewees have commonly appeal to their interest
in learning new technology
and are willing to go outdoors
for learning it.
And they express their preference in learning together
with people who share similar challenges.
One thing to note about older adults demographics in Korea
is that they demonstrate high confidence
in using smartphones as well.
Based on these needs-finding,
we thought holding p5.js workshop
specifically dedicated to older adults
itself can contribute to in increasing
the learning opportunity for older population.
In fact, coding education has actively been adopted
in both public and formal,
and private and informal institutions
over the last decades in Korea.
And learning resources are getting
bountiful both online and off-line.
However, those materials and curriculums
are not very suitable for 50+ people.
I think Inhwa can talk more about this.
right Inhwa?
- Yes thank you Seonghyeon.
So we started designing this workshop in consideration
of the technical access of older adults to coding devices.
Like in our formative interview,
the older adults demonstrated their confidence
and familiarity to smartphones,
so we thought we should devise a way through
which they can access with smartphones
the p5.js learning resources.
and also to utilize web editor without a separate
or a refreshed window
and what's even better is that
we can utilize the smartphone to learn the p5.js anytime
and anywhere we want.
And in this talk,
actually we've also planned to introduce
our p5 for 50+ workshop,
our experiences there,
but due to the rebursting of COVID-19
unfortunately it's been delayed to late November
and yet the overview of the workshop we can see
from the current slide.
So if you're also interested in learning more about this
workshop itself and the actual voice of older adults
on their experiences of learning p5.js with smartphones,
please stay tuned till then.
But before everything and in preparing for,
p5.js workshop in Korea especially
for those workshops that are targeting older adults,
the Korean translation of materials is a must.
So it is important to know that the English,
it comes as a double bind for non English speaking people
when learning coding since code is written in English
and most of the learning materials
in online forums circulate in English.
So as a part of minimizing this lingual barrier,
we translated the official website of p5.js in Korean,
so that not only our worship participants,
but also the entire Korean speaking population can better
access to bountiful resources on this website.
Just one thing to note,
the sketch backgrounds was created by Seonghyeon
in celebration of launching Korean version of the website.
Seonghyeon can you briefly talk about your work too?
- Thank you Inhwa.
So the artwork is my re-interpretation
of “Hunminjeongeum” with p5.js.
Hunminjeongeum means the native script
of the Korean characters and language invented and promulgated
by King Sejong in 1446.
I found much similarity between King Sejong's intention
of creating Hangul characters with the sprit of p5.js.
especially in terms of enhancing everyone's accessibility
to lingual experiences.
- Yeah, so likewise in our project outcomes,
we try to include not only Korean,
but also the average English and digital utilization level
of older adults to re-adjust the learning materials.
So in that sense,
we also thought that unlike the usual way of learning coding
p5.js can be particularly helpful in enhancing older adults
understanding of coding and multi-sensory manners.
We thought it was crucial to offer a wide variety
of options for exploring example of sketches
with readily accessible codes through p5.js web editor.
So this way they can try out the interaction
and tweak with codes and see how the entire
process of programming works like
from their inputs to outputs.
And if you're also looking for p5.js sketches,
you might want to explore this showcase.p5js.org
Is the p5.js 2020 showcase website produced
and curated by Connie Liu.
It introduces 60 and more p5.js projects
that are categorized under specific themes
or interactions such as data visualization,
game, sound, typography, etc.
So all of these aforementioned ideas to our project,
are capstone in this prototype,
you can access on p5 for 50+,
Like we've constantly emphasized we discovered
the strong needs for a learning interface that's specially
designed for 50+ people.
Our interviewees demonstrated "higher confidence in using
a smartphone than desktop PCs or laptops."
So we managed to create a mobile base web application,
so that they can access p5.js materials
and the web editor simply through a single URL
on their smartphones.
Again anytime and anywhere they want
and without the barrier or the burden of carrying
around a laptop or tablet,
or without downloading an application on their phone.
In case p5.js web editor,
we embedded that in our application so that the learners
can practice coding, customize example codes
save and manage their codes without a separate
or refreshed window.
So this prototype it's basically like a simplified version
of p5js.org which is the official website of p5.js.
We kept the structure and design elements of p5js.org
but use less texts and bigger fonts,
made more visual elements and interactions come to the front
and placed more focused on the basic concepts
of computer programming would hopefully
an easier user flow.
The official website of p5.js is re-introduced as advanced
information through hyperlinks.
So when we propose the p5 for 50+ web application
[we're doing so] as a stepping stone towards the official website
or any other resources that are bountiful
but text oriented.
This is to boost the age groups confidence
in self learning through smartphones.
We hope that the users feel at ease
and have fun while exploring the web application
and then eventually move on to p5js.org
or other resources or hyperlinks
for more in depth knowledge
without being overwhelmed
by the depths of it at first sight.
So in our p5 for 50+,
we'll be fully utilizing this web application
in line with analog or tangible media and contents.
In our case we're using pen markers and color papers
so that the participants can actually draw sketches
that they want to code later or write down codes.
And we're printing out the code sketches in A4 size
we're framing the sketches so that the participants
can have a mini exhibition
and take away their materialized results of coding.
As we're brainstorming on their code sketches,
we're asking them to recall their personal memory
and stories as the means to reinforce their cognition.
Such tasks included the visualization
of their own writing,
the daily writing or their self portrait
of their past, present or future selves,
drawings of their beloved living creatures,
objects or a roadmap to their favorite places
and their neighborhood landscaping, etc.
In designing the curriculum we have not only referred
to cognition reinforcement education programs
for older adults,
but also the learning methodology and materials demonstrated
at other p5.js workshops and classes.
So for your reference, we'd like to introduce that
you can now access information
to p5.js workshops and classes
and relevant teaching materials through this page
that's newly launching this September.
The URL is p5.js.org/teach
and the page was designed to document
and share p5.js teaching experiences around the world.
It's constantly receiving submissions
on the teaching cases,
so if you got any you might want to
consider sharing yours through this web page as well.
As for our workshop, we have referred
to these two workshops in particular,
which you can also check out
on the teach page.
So on the left, you can see Lauren McCarthy’s workshop,
who is the very creator of p5.js and also the advisor
to our project.
So Lauren has led the "Smarter Home" workshop
in South Korea last year,
where a fair amount of participants
were middle aged and older
and they engaged in the two months long collaborative
p5 projects for an exhibition.
Her experience led us ponder more on the re-engagement
and sustainability issue of learning coding.
So to quote her
"Teaching coding sometimes
is not about losing people,
it is about how to keep them engaged instead of scaring them away."
Now on the right side, you can see Qianqian Ye
and Evelyne Masso's workshop
Qianqian was mentor to our project
and together with Evelyn she led
a series of workshop called "Digital Weaving
physical computing".
And this workshop participants transformed their codes
into tangible materials such as fabric.
Their workshop has let us think more about how we can
leverage tangible materials and interactions
and then to promote it in more intuitive and affectionate
way of learning coding.
So combining our research and the insight
from our mentor and advisor,
as well as other p5 educators,
we could devised principles for designing p5 for 50+ workshops.
So we believe a p5.js workshop can start
from asking the reason why participants would want
to learn coding and how the experience
can be beneficial for them.
This is not only to inform them of social
cultural functions and effects of computer programming and
the contemporary society,
but also to keep them motivated throughout the workshop.
Now keeping the learning materials and environment
physically and emotionally accessible
is never too much to emphasize.
In our case, we've considered their physical accessibility
to computing devices,
the lingual accessibility,
and the universal design of learning interfaces.
And these three in a row,
we can talk about it all together at once.
So we think it's important to utilize multi-sensory elements
of p5.js sensorializing the participant's personal narratives
and then materialize the results from digital
to analog media so that they can take away
their learning experience with a souvenir.
We're also considering the souvenir as an
at-home device for recalling their memories of learning coding
so that they won't forget to re-access p5for50.plus
when they wish to continue learning.
Once again to emphasize,
this is one common methodology actively
employed in the fields of gerontology or to studies
of the older adults or studies or rehabilitation
in terms of improving the 50+ learner s'
understanding of, concentration on, and affection towards what
they are learning.
Providing a time and space for social interactions with
other people in the midst of workshops would be helpful.
By social interactions we mean those moments where
you can communicate with those people who share
similar backgrounds,
interests and challenges.
or better yet with their own family members
Note that in case of Korea,
the alienation and generational gap issues are
our biggest challenges to older adults.
Last but not least important to note that
for educator themselves to enjoy their moments of teaching!
So let us enjoy teaching and learning from our participants!
This is all for our presentation.
Thank you very much for attention.
And if you have any questions,
please do not hesitate to leave comments to this video,
or send us an email.
Thank you very much.